[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARIE MEIR: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Arie Meir.
I'm a product manager in
Google Cloud health care.
My team is focusing on
medical imaging solutions.
So it's my privilege
and pleasure today
to host Dr. Kitamura, visiting
us from Hiroshima, Japan.
He and his team are
here to tell you
a little bit about an
interesting company called
MNES and their work.
So I actually learned
about MNES's work
from a friend of mine,
and one of the things
I found especially
interesting is
that they were able to build
a full tailored radiology
solution, cloud native--
so they started from the cloud--
and they did it
without ever speaking
to anyone technical in Google.
So they're using AI, they're
using a full radiologist stack.
They built their own viewer, and
they have full-time developers,
they have full-time
radiologists on their team.
They will tell you more--
but without ever
speaking to Google.
So that's one of the examples
of a self-service customer.
So I would like to start
by showing you a quick clip
to give you a
high-level overview,
and then we're going
to be discussing
different aspects of this work.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
Thank you.
So before we move on
to the presentation,
I would like to suggest you
look for the movie stars
among-- because there
are some people near you.
But Dr. Kitamura,
welcome to Cloud Next.
It's a pleasure having you here.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Thank you, too.
It's great to be here.
ARIE MEIR: So tell us a
little bit about MNES.
What does your company do?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: After
graduating from university,
my first job was a radiologist
at a big hospital in Hiroshima.
I saw money in [INAUDIBLE]
in clinical practice,
which I wanted to address.
MNES is a teleradiologist
company based in Hiroshima,
providing radiology scientist
to hospital [INAUDIBLE]
ARIE MEIR: So what
was the problem
you were trying to address?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
One day a patient
was brought to the hospital.
She was 37-year-old with
advanced pancreatic cancer.
I checked her previous
results of medical checkup
from six months ago.
I examined the old CT image,
and yes, the cancer was there,
and it was missed.
ARIE MEIR: So how
does this happen?
How does one miss a cancer?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: The
patient had her CT scan
at this small village
with limited access
to a radiologist.
It was a misdiagnosis that
could have been prevented.
This incident broke my
heart, and opened my eyes.
This is why I started my company
MNES to focus on teleradiology
and bring expertise
where it's most needed.
ARIE MEIR: So in your mind, how
does teleradiology help here?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: Before I
explain how teleradiology
can help you, let me start
with you three dimensions
of the challenges.
The first dimension
is the ratio of number
of a radiologists to the
number of images created.
The second dimension is
geographical ignorance
of Japan as an island nation.
And finally the third dimension
is the social uniqueness
of health care system.
ARIE MEIR: Interesting.
So what do you mean
when you say, the ratio?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: Here is some
data on radiology [INAUDIBLE]
in Japan and the US.
If you look at the number of CT
and MRI units in each country,
you'll see that US and
Japan are pretty close.
But if you look at the
number of radiologists,
you will see that
USA has 10 times
the number of radiologists
compared to Japan.
When I recently chatted
with an American colleague,
he was shocked that
a non-specialist
like an internist can make
a radiology interpretation.
In the US, once a
mis-diagnosis happens,
it often leads to a
malpractice lawsuit.
In Japan the situation
is different,
and it is far from ideal.
ARIE MEIR: So I understand
how this difference drives
you to make it more effective.
What about geography?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: Because of the
geographical regions in Japan,
we also have a very uneven
distribution of doctors.
Most of them are concentrated
in large urban areas.
This makes rural areas very
starved for specialist access.
My hometown is a
perfect example.
Hiroshima prefecture
is surrounded
by islands and
mountainous areas,
with limited access
to specialists.
Compare it to the
map of California,
and you can see how
teleradiology or telemedicine
become very relevant.
ARIE MEIR: I see.
So lots of islands,
difficult to access,
all the experts are
centralized in big cities.
What about-- you mentioned
there is a third dimension,
so social aspect.
What do you mean by that?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: Yes.
In the Japanese society
a female radiologist
often has to give up work to
support their young family.
This contributes even more
to scarcity of radiologists.
For these three reasons,
I believe teleradiology
is extremely relevant in Japan.
ARIE MEIR: I see.
So it makes sense because I
guess your platform enables
them to work part-time.
Tell us how you
approach teleradiology.
Are you a service company?
Are you a product company?
What exactly are
you focusing on?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: MNES provides
a response in two ways.
On the one hand, MNES
is a product company.
Our product mainly is LOOKREC.
On the other hand, MNES
is a service company.
These two complement each other.
ARIE MEIR: So what
exactly is the product?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: Our product
enables the radiologist
to provide reading services
remotely to clinics.
Here's a movie of how we LOOKREC
software to make diagnosis.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PLAYBACK ENDS]
ARIE MEIR: We Have
some technical issues.
Just a second.
Teleradiology platforms
have their limits.
[INAUDIBLE REMARK FROM STAFF
MEMBER]
ARIE MEIR: OK.
Let me try to
refresh this maybe.
OK, we're going to
live without it.
So basically, there
are two parts.
One part is the reporting
tool, the other part
is the viewer tool.
So the radiologist essentially
inspects the images
in the viewer, and
simultaneously creates
the report.
You can also select which
slices you want to view,
and you can manipulate
the images in order
to make the correct diagnosis.
OK, so tell us a little bit
about the service component,
Kitamura-san.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: MNES has
two types of radiologist.
We have 11 full-time
radiologists
providing reading services
using the LOOKREC platform
to our partner clinics.
We also have
part-time radiologists
to address changes in demand.
We think of our platform
as Uber for radiology
to meet the dynamic
market demand.
ARIE MEIR: So I hope
you're not going
to start hiring Uber drivers
for your teleradiologists.
But tell us about who pays for
the teleradiology services.
Is it the patient pays, or
is it the insurance company?
How does that work in Japan?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: We have
customers for both options.
All Japanese people have
government health care plan
which covers for some
radiology services.
Some of our partners, for
example, Ginza Clinic,
offer direct-to-consumer
imaging checkup,
which includes a brain MRI, plus
interpretation three experts--
radiologist, cardiologist,
and neuroradiologist
for less than $200.
ARIE MEIR: So just--
this was a shocking number
for me when I heard this.
So basically Japanese are known
to be very interested in health
checkups, so there are private
companies, direct-to-consumer,
that offer a brain MRI scan
for $200, completely paid
by the customer, that offer
a checkup by a radiologist,
a neuroradiologist, and a
cardiologist, for aneurysms.
So how does that make sense?
Because this number,
$200, is extremely low
compared to the US,
where a brain MRI
can cost north of $2000.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: That's
a complicated question.
Let me offer two data points.
A typical salary for Japanese
radiologist is around $120,000.
Do you know what is a typical
salary for a US radiologist.
ARIE MEIR: I think it's higher.
So just, I want to
reiterate number.
So I'm not a radiologist,
but the numbers
are like three or
four times higher.
$120,000 for a
radiologist in Japan.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Another data point.
Malpractice insurance in
Japan costs $600 a year.
In the US, my understanding
is that this number
is much higher.
ARIE MEIR: Does
anyone actually know
how much malpractice
for radiologists
cost in a representative state?
AUDIENCE: So then 15 years
ago it was around $50,000.
ARIE MEIR: $50,000.
And it depends on state.
It varies if you--
depends where you live,
between $20,000 and $200,000.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: So
I'm not sure about that.
The other fact is that
this difference really
contributes to the cost.
ARIE MEIR: Yeah, so
I understand if you
have your own radiologist, or
if you don't have a radiologist
but you have imaging equipment,
you can benefit from LOOKREC.
How about clinics that don't
even have imaging devices?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Very good question.
For this case, we all
mobile CT service.
Mobile CT's are a dedicated
truck loaded with a CT scanner.
It helps us serve rural
areas without a CT scanner.
We drive this mobile
CT to where it's needed
and get people scanned.
We also use it for
employee screening
since Japanese law requires
employers to offer this service
to their employees once a year.
ARIE MEIR: So this was a
very interesting insight.
So my team had the privilege
of visiting MNES in Japan
a couple of months ago, and
we actually visited this van.
We were inside this van.
And Kitamura-san's
technician offered
us to run a presentation.
So none of us
wanted to volunteer
for ionizing
radiation, but we had
the little anecdote I remember.
So we had the little
bento box lunch
that the technician
had that day,
and he said that his
wife made it for him.
And he said, I don't
know what's in it.
I have not seen it.
So he put it in the
CT and he scanned it,
and we were able to
figure out the rice,
and the little tamagoyaki.
It was like lots of
interesting insights.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, by
law, they have to give--
ARIE MEIR: So employers in
Japan are required by law
to offer an annual checkup
that includes a lung cancer
screening.
Very interesting difference.
AUDIENCE: They don't
worry about dose?
ARIE MEIR: That's an
interesting question.
Yeah, I think there is
a different approach
to risk management in Japan.
It was insightful
for me as well.
I think that they also
try to striate patients.
So they-- obviously
you kind of have
to hit the right
demographics, and then it
becomes more relevant.
So Kitamura-san, what is your
vision for MNES in the future?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
So far I have been
talking about teleradiology
model as it is now.
But this is only a first step.
In the future I
envision three steps.
First, teleradiology;
second, image-based AI,
algorithms that primarily look
at the images for prediction
AI; third, holistic AI,
algorithms that look at other
data--
genomics, demographics,
nutrition --for prediction.
ARIE MEIR: I see.
So I understand what image-based
AI is, so you primarily
look at images.
Can you tell us more
specifics about it?
How are you using AI?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Image diagnosis in AI
is algorithms that use images
as primary data source.
We have started working
with different types
of AI applications.
Let me give you three examples
we are already using today.
AI that can detect
brain aneurysm,
which is abnormal blood vessel.
Breast cancer is already used
in daily clinical practice.
CT lung nodule AI detector
for cancer diagnostics.
Interesting to note that the AI
models have different quality.
For example, AI for
brain aneurysm detection
has 85% sensitivity,
which makes it
a useful tool to double-check
human radiologist.
Let's play a movie to
demonstrate how we are
using AI in LOOKREC product.
ARIE MEIR: So this
was actually--
before we play the movie,
I want to point out
that this was a fascinating
discovery because MNES is using
AI algorithms already embedded
in their clinical workflow,
and these algorithms
are still in the process
of clinical validation.
But the specific algorithm,
the brain aneurysm Kitamura-san
mentioned-- the brain--
the breast cancer
detection for MRI images,
and the CT lung nodule detector.
It was very
interesting, especially
to see the feedback
collection piece,
which you will see in a second.
I hope there is
sound on this one.
No sound.
OK, so I'm going to make
a voiceover for this.
So essentially
what you see here,
the pictures are being
sent to the cloud.
The AI detects what is
the right algorithm.
In this case, this
is a brain aneurysm,
and it detects that
this is a brain MRI,
so you have to apply
[INAUDIBLE] and then
the AI operates by detecting
all the places where
it suspects aneurysm to appear.
All the results of the AI
are here on the right side,
and what the screen allows
the radiologist to do
is to provide feedback.
So for each one of these
findings, the radiologist has
to say, true positive, which
means that AI was right,
or it marks as false
positive, which
means that the AI was wrong.
Once the feedback has collected,
you can press Send Feedback,
and that is being sent to the
developer of the algorithm.
Obviously sometimes
the AI misses things.
This is the false negatives.
So this is an opportunity
for the doctor to provide--
to point and click where
the AI missed the diagnosis.
So this information is being
used by the application
developer in order to improve
the algorithm continuously.
So this is how the
user invokes the AI,
and this is the
feedback screen again.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: I use
this AI system every day.
Image diagnosis with
AI will be the standard
in the near future.
But we radiologists should
not rely too much on AI.
If you trust AI completely
and don't make diagnosis
on your own, your
diagnostic ability
will decline in no time.
ARIE MEIR:
[INAUDIBLE] thank you.
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: We should
keep on upgrading our ability,
and send the diagnostic
results to AI.
That would improve
AI's accuracy,
therefore it would be
a benefit for patients.
ARIE MEIR: So you know
the loaded question,
the elephant in the room.
Are there any
radiologists in the room?
OK, maybe no elephant here.
But I can tell you, when we gave
a similar talk in RSNA, which
is the Radiology Society
of North America, which
is 30,000 radiologists getting
in the middle of the winter,
in Chicago.
The question is like,
so what's going on here?
Is AI going to
replace radiologists?
So Kitamura-san, what
is your take on this?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: This is
indeed a loaded question.
I know that there
is a healthy debate
in my professional
radiology community.
Here is what I think will
happen in the near future.
First, we will see
that over time, AI
will keep bringing more and
more value as a decision support
tool to help human radiologists
make more precise decisions.
Second, we know that human
radiologists are valued
for their experience, so we will
help human radiologist focus
on the truly difficult cases.
ARIE MEIR: Hm.
So one additional data
point I would like to add
is that the meme you
hear in this space
is that AI is not going
to replace radiologists,
but the radiologists
that are using AI
will replace radiologists
that are not using AI.
Because it is like
saying, OK, I'm
not going to use the internet.
But if this is a
tool that allows
you to be more productive
and provide better
care for your patients,
you are not competitive
if you're not going to use it.
So another thing is to think
about AI in this context,
it's not one black
box that solves
all the problems
of the world, just
like an auto-pilot in a
plane is not one instrument.
It is a collection--
if you ever looked
into a cockpit of a
commercial airline,
you know that it's a
collection of instruments.
Each one is very dedicated,
very focused, and solves
a very particular problem.
Now an auto-pilot
is a collection,
and they all work in
tandem with each other,
and they help the pilot
make better decisions.
The pilot is still the one
who makes the final decisions,
especially in the complicated
cases like taking off, landing,
or during turbulence.
So the same thing it is my view
that will happen in this space.
We will see more
and more tools--
like the ones that
Kitamura-san mentioned
--developed and being
helpful to radiologists
to make them more productive.
So I also think that there
are a couple of questions
that the whole space is trying
to figure out specifically
around regulatory approval.
How do you think about
FDA approval of AI model
that by definition is not fixed.
You know, medical device--
fixed.
You sign off the sheets,
you manufacture it,
and you're done.
If you want to make
a new device you
need to apply for
regulatory approval again.
AI, by definition, is
something evolving.
So FDA right now
is also evolving
in how it thinks about
regulatory approval for AI
applications.
It also-- will actually
work with the FDA
closely in their
program where they
try to adjust their approach.
Specifically, until
now, the FDA has
been focusing on providing
regulatory approval
to products.
Now they're more
experimenting with the idea
that they can provide regulatory
approval to a process.
So if you are compliant
with a process,
and they approve
that process, it
allows you to have more freedom
to operate an experiment.
Very exciting times.
So Kitamura-san, thank you.
These were great
examples, I think,
and the feedback
collection piece I think
is very interesting.
Can you talk a little
bit about holistic AI,
and your vision for that?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Holistic AI means
using more than imaging data.
We want to help patients
collect different data types--
medical record data, genomics
data, nutrition data,
medication data, exercise
data, sleep data.
Think of LOOKREC as Google
Drive for medical records.
Once this data is in
the cloud, MNES AI
can analyze it and make
useful recommendations.
We have already started a
centralized management system,
including medical
interviews, medical cure,
and pathological imaging, in
addition to radiologic imaging.
To integrate all the data,
we use a Google account.
Here in this room, some
of you may have already
started working on
innovative AI applications.
We are very interested to
collaborate with partners
to accelerate our mission.
Please come talk to us.
ARIE MEIR: So Kitamura-san,
until now, you
have been focusing on Japan.
Are you only working in Japan?
Are you thinking of going
outside of the country?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Thank you, Arie.
Your question has good timing.
We are very interested
to go global.
Let me give you an example.
This month, we launched
a collaborative project
between Japan and Mongolia to
help doctors in that country
improve their radiologic
diagnostic quality.
The way it works is through
the network system of MNES
that connect the two countries.
When diagnostic radiologists
or pathologists in Mongolia
face a difficult
case, they can consult
with experts based in Japan.
It's similar to having senior
doctors advising junior doctors
in a teaching setting.
This helps patients,
and also helps improve
skills for Mongolian doctors.
ARIE MEIR: Very interesting.
So Kitamura-san, you
are now in Cloud Next.
Tell us a little about
your cloud journey.
How did you end up
choosing-- why Google?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
Many of our staff
already use Google services,
including Gmail, Calendar,
and Drive.
We wanted to build
the teleradiology
as a service as
simple as logging
in to your Gmail account.
Also Google Drive is a place
where people store their files.
We want to build a place
where people can store
their medical images and data.
We also wanted partner
of measurable size
that would enable us to develop
telemedicine services that
would be reliable and scalable.
We also have global goals, and
we wanted a global partner.
Most importantly we
saw Google as a partner
with a vision that
is aligned to ours,
democratized access to
high-quality care, universally.
We see our goal achieved
through telemedicine.
ARIE MEIR: So it sounds like
you had quite a checklist
for your requirements.
I'm happy that we were able
to meet your expectations,
Kitamura-san.
Thank you.
I wanted to ask you about some
of the challenges around cloud.
So in the US we're learning that
health space, financial space,
and other regulated
industries like government,
they're slowly
warming up to the idea
of using clouds for their
data storage and processing.
How is this happening in Japan?
What kind of challenges
were you facing
when you were approaching
health care providers?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: We have indeed
observed a gradual increase
in willingness to use cloud
solutions in the health care
space, and we think
it's very exciting.
We think it has to
do with two reasons.
First, large financial
institutions in Japan
are moving to the cloud, and
that sends a strong signal
to other industries
like health care.
Second, because Japan
produces so much imaging data,
the cost efficiency of
storing the data on-premise
becomes less and less
economical for hospitals.
They are looking for
effective solutions,
and here cloud can
provide real value.
ARIE MEIR: Interesting.
So when you're
deploying LOOKREC,
is it like a pure cloud,
or a hybrid approach?
How does that work?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA:
In the present,
because many of
our customers are
asking for additional
backup storage,
we offer a hybrid solution.
We keep most of the data in
the data center in Tokyo,
and some of the data
on-premise in the hospital.
We also know that Google is
planning to open another data
center in Osaka.
This will enable us to move to a
pure cloud solution, which will
make our IT management easier.
ARIE MEIR: Makes sense.
So as we are about
to wrap up, what
are you most excited about
the future, Kitamura-san?
Where do you see the
most opportunity here?
NAOYUKI KITAMURA: I'm
excited about three things.
First, I want to see MNES become
a truly global initiative,
bringing specialist expertise
where it's needed the most.
Second, we want to advance the
role of AI in teleradiology.
We want to integrate
more AI algorithms
into our clinical work.
Third, we want to
find partners that
can use our platform to solve
problems like rare diseases.
If any of these resonate with
you, please come talk to us.
We are welcoming
potential collaboration.
We would to make
LOOKREC a tool that
can improve patients' lives.
This is our mission, and
nothing would make me happier
than that.
ARIE MEIR: Thank
you, Kitamura-san.
I think this is going
to-- to wrap up,
one of the examples of a
very fruitful partnership--
because LOOKREC brings a lot
of the products Google is
building, showcasing what
is possible to do with them,
and it also enables other
partners, the ones that
develop the AI
applications, to be tested,
accelerated, and
developed further.
So this is an example of how
Google Cloud is approaching
the partner-first
ecosystem in order
to solve very specific
challenges in the health care
space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]